I already know you know yes sir yes sir
in their nighttime you're killing me bro
what's that blue truck for I'm out here
mamas sports encounter with my dog Tiger
Lee on his day off so today is hot and I
haven't be working out and playing some
NBA 2k on Google's new gaming platform
stadia where you can game anywhere
anytime you ready to lose yeah we're
about to hit the treadmill placing 2k so
your controllers right here everything
should be working so let's get it let's
go yeah of course in there
I'm not to run you off the sticks come
on Melo bucket that's easy
Thank You Todd you usually play games
that you're in or you try to try to stay
away from that little batter here there
you use yourself are usually dominate of
course I bet you run every time - yeah
30 carries yeah you get this set up
man I just plugged in the chromecast as
long as you have Wi-Fi you're good to go
uh-huh no you got CJ McCullen you're
gonna make threes every time you get
scored on you got to go up a ticket
there no more yes sir
in there that's how you're killing me
bro
going all the way up now you got to pick
that controller back bro oh dude a
mellow yeah buckets come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah being in LA
what's that like playing the game that
way I don't have to bring a whole game
console all I have to literally do is
bring a controller that's gonna make
everything way back I talk now we're at
recovery so I'm getting these ice baths
you first
any advice for go in no just go away and
don't think about it
yeah yeah what do you think about the
stadium man like a man super curvy
mm-hmm Israa yo ice bat from your own
question
youichi I'm definitely cheating a little
bit
I know what my time you got me all in
the codes of reason I'm a practicing all
week for this too and I really came a
crazy short and you know what's crazy I
was buying my best player I don't even
pray you're so taught to get one of
these you gotta have the city about cops
get your stadium premier edition
appreciating you let us join you on your
off day sure no prob again yes sir
no I'm not this we're gonna play the
game again sure the hell out of these
ice bat
[Music]
[Applause]